you know one of the things i learned
from warren buffett
which helped me
uh
do well in life and also be able to set
up dakshina and all
is
um i i learned from buffett uh
the power of compounding
and i know some of you
or many of you
are not pcm students
but even if you're not pcm students soda
power of compounding jhana
a child
it may help you in life
so
so this is one of the most important
only two things warren buffett figured
out
he figured our power of compounding when
he was 10 years old
and
and it was a big advantage for him in
life
so
i think you guys might know the story
the like the guy who invented
the game of chess
and
the king in that kingdom became
[Music]
an addicted player of chess
and he was so happy with the inventor he
said
ask for any reward and i'll give it to
you
so he said that i don't want much
i just want you to put one grain of rice
on the first
first square of the chess board and then
two grains on the second
second square
four grains on the third square and keep
doubling the grains
and till the 64th square and that's all
i want
and uh so the king got kind of upset
with him he said i wanted to give you
all these things you just want a bunch
of rice he said yeah i just want a bunch
of rice so he told his treasurer
give him his rice and get him out of my
court
so
after a few days
the king asked the treasurer why he had
not
finished the job he said sir
it took us a while to run the
calculation
but
we don't have the rice
so the king was very upset what do you
mean you don't have the rice he says
we don't have that much rice in the
whole kingdom to give him
so you know
like
you know the first square is one grain
plus two grains plus four grains
all the way to
two to the power of 63 right
in the 64th square
what is this equal to
easy
much easier than your je questions
what is 1 plus 2 plus 4 plus 8 plus 16
plus 32 all the way to
because you know this is uh let me make
it easier for you to the power 0 plus 2
to the power 1 plus 2 to the power 2
plus 2 to the power 63
what's that equal to
this is uh 2 to the power of 64 minus 1.
okay
you can work it out later how i got that
but
2 to the power 64 minus 1 grains of rice
if i convert that into kilograms
and then i convert it based on the price
of the rice
it is about
this is about
300 trillion dollars
and 300 trillion dollars
is just about the wealth of the entire
planet
not just rice if i include all the
land and buildings and gold and
money everyone has in the whole world
that's 300 trillion
so that's what the guy asked for
okay
so
so
one of the things that warren buffett
figured out and what einstein said
einstein said that compounding is the
eighth wonder of the world
right and the
so what he
so for example
let's say
i have
one lakh rupees
okay
and let's say for example this one lakh
rupees
is increasing at 26 per year
some bank is giving me very high
interest rate 26
okay
so
in three years
this will be
approximately doubled
times 1.26 and 1.26 it'll be
about approximately two
so what happens in three years is
it becomes two lakhs
right and how much is it in six years
how much is it in six years
four lakhs
and then in
nine years
eight lakhs
so
so let's say
someone is uh
20 years old
and they have
one lakh
and they are
increasing at 26 a year
how much will they have when they are 50
years old so one lakh then 23 per 2
lakhs 26 by 4 lakhs
29 by 8 lakhs you keep going
so
it's 30 years from 20 to 50 right
every three years you're doubling so
it's uh
two to the power of ten
that's one zero two four
right
yeah
so it will become
10 crores
right
1000 times one lakh
is ten crores right
now
let's say we go till the age of eighty
another thirty years
so
what will become to the ten crores
it will become
10 000 crores
right
we started with one lakh
at 20
and we never saved any money after that
we only had the one lakh
and it became so warren buffett figured
this out
at uh
the age of 10
and then he did a lot of part-time jobs
when he was growing up like as a
teenager when he was 20 years old
he had
10 000 dollars
which is about like seven lakhs now
so
he had 10 000
when he was 20 years old
and then when when this was in 1950
and when i heard of him for the first
time in 1994
uh he had compounded this at 30 a year
okay from 1950 to 1994. so it's 45 years
right from 50 to 94.
and 30 a year there's something known as
rule of 72.
how many of you know rule of 72 have you
ever heard of rule of 72
third year iit may google now
so anyway rule of 72
at 30 percent
the money doubles every 2.5 years
you know at 26 we were doubling every
three years
so in 45 years
how many doubles are there
there are four doubles in 10 years
16 doubled in 40 years
and another two doubles in five years so
2 to the power 18.
so 2 to the power 18
this is equal to the power 10 times 2 to
the power 8
this is equal to 1000
times 250
right approximately 1024 times 256.
don't do approximations on the je paper
only do it over here
so this is 250
000
times 10 000.
so
that's 2500
zero
zero zero zero zero
so
it's
2.5 billion
in rupees
this is
17
500 crores
okay from the 10 000.
but then that was in 94.
that time he was uh
he was how old he was 64 years old
so then
another 25 years have gone by
on
that compounding engine on that
17500 crores
so
when you run that engine for another 25
years
he becomes the richest person in the
world
like the chessboard guy
so
to
give you an answer on dakshina 2.0
i had to explain this to you
because
i
when i heard of buffett in 94
i said
she's a
college boy or school
you know
like what's the point of calculus
you know i still haven't used calculus
but that's okay
[Music]
you